the same thing is coming for all of us
[Music]
there is only one war with apostasy
the Great Wall
and it is here
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 discussion video I wanted to do
something a little different with this
video so I figured I would list 10 of
the biggest theories that have yet to
come true I actually made this video
about 6 months ago but YouTube put
copyright claims on that video and they
will not have returned them I tried to
download the video off my channel that
way I could we upload it as soon as
possible but I'm not able to do that
either since there are claims on it so I
am making the entire thing over from
scratch my apologies if you did see the
original version but I am doing a new
giveaway for those of you who want to
stay until the end of the video I will
go over the details then but let's begin
as we all know there are probably
hundreds or even thousands of theories
but today I only want to list 10 of them
these are some of the ones that I hear
or see people talking about the most
they aren't in any specific order but I
think it's safe to assume people would
like to know if these ones are true or
not even if only half of these came true
it would make for an epic season if
there are any theories you like that I
left off of this list please put them
down in the comment section as well now
let's get started number 1 the valonqar
this one is a little controversial
because when Cersei Lannister met Maggie
the frog in the television show they
left this part of the prophecy out which
leads some people to believe they might
not have Cersei died by the hands of the
valonqar Cersei was told that she would
not marry Prince Rhaegar but she would
marry the king instead and that did
happen
Cersei was also told that she would have
three kids and they would die that has
already happened - the only thing is
they left one of the most interesting
parts of the prophecy out which may have
foreshadowed says his own death in this
part of the prophecy Maggie tells Cersei
and when your tears have drowned you the
valonqar shall wrap his hands about your
pale white throat and choke the life
from you although they decided to leave
this part out it hasn't stopped fans
from guessing who will choke Cersei to
death there are many different theories
about who the valonqar could actually be
some people say it's Jaime Lannister
while others say it's Tyrion Lannister
or even Arya Stark personally I would
like to see Jaime Lannister be the one
to do this
I think that would be the most
satisfying way to end Circe's story even
though Jamie no longer has two hands I
believe he could still do this if he
truly wanted to number two Jon Snow
rides a dragon this is another very
popular theory that has been around for
over a decade now that the knight king
has a dragon I would like to see Jon
ride a dragon and face off against him
in the sky alongside Daenerys it has now
been 100% confirmed in the show that
John has Targaryen blood so I think hem
riding a dragon is very possible not
only does John have the blood of the
Dragon but we have also seen him already
begin to form a bond with the Dragons
Daenerys only has two dragons left and
she can't ride both of them at the same
time
someone needs to ride ragel into battle
the night king was able to take down
Viserion with ease but i think it would
be much harder if all of the dragons had
riders we know Rhaegar was named after
Rhaegar which is John's father so it
makes sense to me that John would ride
that dragon now that we only have six
episodes left HBO needs to make this
happen at least one time before the show
ends number three cleganebowl fans have
been wanting to see how this showdown
will end ever since season 1 but the
hyper cleganebowl reached an all-time
high
after the Hound confronted his brother
in the dragon pit when the Hound came
face-to-face with his brother on the
dragon pit he told him he knew who was
coming for him he's always known and
that person is the Hound he has one of
his brother dead ever since he was a
little boy in that time may finally come
during season eight Arya Stark still has
the mountain on her list and I know some
people would like to see her be the one
to kill him
but I would prefer if the Hound did the
deed himself that would be the most
satisfying way to do it in my opinion
but I'm also not against Arya helping
him in some way if they want to double
penetrate the mountain with their swords
then by all means have at it number four
brain stark warg Vissarion
this might be one of the theories that
is least likely to happen but it's still
a very popular one nonetheless
brain stark is one of the most powerful
characters in the story and we have
already seen him war
into many different animals and even
Hodor but the ultimate showstopper would
be if bran stark could warg into a
dragon the full extent of brains powers
are still yet to be seen but it's very
obvious he has a strong connection what
the night came
we know the night King was able to
physically interact with brain while
they were inside of the weirwood net but
now that brain is starting to learn how
to harness his powers he may be able to
tap into the night Kings powers and
possibly take over his dragon Jojen Reed
did say the most powerful warg
could wear the skins of any beast that
crawls swims or flies
so maybe bran will have the ability to
control dragons next season bran will
never be able to walk again but he can
fly number five Daenerys Targaryen will
have a baby now this theory is somewhat
new but there is more than enough
evidence to lead me to believe it will
come true
ever since season 1 Daenerys has been
under the impression that she can no
longer have children and that may have
been true back then but it is no longer
true now marry master told Daenerys that
only death can pay for life and I think
as soon as Viserion died his sacrifice
will allow Daenerys to have a child his
death will pay for the life of her baby
Jorah Mormont also foreshadowed John
having children and even John told
Daenerys that maybe marry masters
prophecy wasn't true there was so much
force shadowing over the course of
season 7 I would actually be surprised
if this did not happen in my opinion I
feel like this one is a guarantee but we
shall see number 6
King's Landing is destroyed this theory
continues to gain steam and it's also
been foreshadowed a few times we saw
glimpses of this happening all the way
back in season 2 when Daenerys enter
visions at the house of the undying
brain stark also touched a weirwood tree
beyond the wall and he saw visions of
King's Landing destroyed given the
current state of Westeros I think this
is very likely to happen Cersei
Lannister has no plans of leaving King's
Landing and now that she has lied to Jon
and Danny's faces this may leave
Daenerys no choice but to remove Cersei
from the city by force we also know
Cersei has no problem with using
wildfire to burn down her own city so
she might even do this herself
my king is also south of the wall and
he's now riding a dragon of his own we
don't know where he plans on going but
if he gets anywhere near King's Landing
then the capital was in deep deep
doo-doo not to mention some spoiler
photos have came out and in those photos
you can see that King's Landing set has
been burned to a certain extent it looks
like only the top of the walls have been
burned which most likely means the fire
came from above by a dragon when you put
everything into consideration I don't
see it ending any other way by the time
the narrow steps foot in the throne room
it will probably look exactly like it
did when she had her visions but only
time will tell
number seven a dance with dragons 2.0 I
think this one is almost a guarantee at
this point and let's be honest a dragon
first dragon battle in the sky would
look incredible anyway this would not be
the first time this has happened but it
would be the first time it has happened
with an undead dragon I don't even think
I need to give much of an explanation
with this theory Daenerys has two
dragons and the night King has one at
some point next season they will face
off in the sky
I just hope John is on one of those
dragons too if you're gonna spend the
big bucks on a CGI dragon battle you
might as well make it a triple threat
match only in this one we need to see
John and Danny first the knight King two
dragons should be able to take down one
right let's hope so
number eight Theon the hero I know this
one might seem like a long shot to some
of you but fian is a new man who was on
a mission after his showdown on the
beach Theon was baptised by the sea when
his dead may never die but rises again
harder and stronger I'm just gonna get
right to the point and say this Theon
must kill his uncle you're on even if
he's not able to save his sister in time
Theon has been on a very long road to
redemption and it almost looked like his
story was coming to an end after he
helped save Sansa but after Yara was
captured in Theon fled it was pretty
clear that his character arc was not yet
over as of right now Theon is on his way
to saving his sister but let's be honest
the odds are not in his favor however I
don't think they kept this character
alive this long to not have his story
end on
no even if he dies in a process of
saving his sister in the end he will not
run like the broken man that he once was
number 9 the azure Ahai prophecy this
one has been around pretty much ever
since the first book came out now that
the story is coming to an end on the
television show this theory is more
relevant now than ever before by the end
of season 8 we will find out if azor
Ahai reborn is a literal and physical
figure or not for those of you that
aren't as familiar with this azor Ahai
was a legendary figure that needed the
forge that he was sword in order to
fight the darkness that was sweeping
over the world every time he tried to
forge the sword it would break until the
third time when he plunged his sword
into nice aneesa's chest when he did
this the sword combined with her heart
and soul then it caught fire turning it
into the red sword of heroes the
followers of real or believed that a
Zora high will be reborn and he will be
the one to end the darkness Melisandre
thinks it's Stannis but once she looks
into the fire all she sees is snow John
even has a dream where he's standing on
top of the wall
dressed in black ice with a burning red
sword in his fist
Melisandre firmly believes in this
prophecy but is it just another story
that has passed down from generation to
generation well Jon Snow's dream become
a reality
I guess we should find out next season
number 10 johnson-odom the night king
this is a theory that I really want to
see come true I would love to see the
night King get slain on the battlefield
or even in the sky while they are on the
Dragons Jon Snow and the knight King
have had two very intense stare down so
far and at some point there needs to be
some kind of a payoff this will
obviously not be an easy task and he's
not gonna be able to do this alone but
if jon is truly the one to lead the
fight against the darkness then he needs
to be the one who defeats the night king
1 verse 1 Jon and Daenerys are on their
way to Winterfell and the night King is
heading that way too so it's only a
matter of time before they come
face-to-face again but the big question
is who
when like I said earlier there are
hundreds or even thousands of theories
out there but I just wanted to list 10
of the theories I see people talking
about all the time if there are any
other ones you want to see come true
next season put them down below now
let's move on to the details about the
giveaway I haven't done one of these in
quite some time so I figured I was long
overdue to give something extra back to
at least one or two subscribers this
time I am giving away two different
prizes so that means there will be two
different winners the first prize is the
complete Game of Thrones series on
blu-ray all seven seasons the second
prize will be the complete A Song of Ice
and Fire book collection all five books
the first person whose name gets picked
will get to choose between these two
prizes the second person whose name gets
picked we'll get the other prize just
click on the link in the description
that way you can be entered into the
drawing the names are randomly selected
by the website and I will draw the first
name in two weeks
that way everyone gets a chance to see
one of my videos and enter good luck
everyone and thank you all for watching
and supporting my videos I really
appreciate that
I also hope you have a great
I will see you again very soon
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you